et pour faire court donc nous avons nous
sommes arrivés à la lfp avec la carnot
il ya un peu plus de 12 mois et on a
traversé une période inédite avec un
un triple tsunami qui allait certes de
la crise sanitaire mais également à
l'arrêt des compétitions on est le seul
pays en france où les compétitions ont
été arrêtés sur décision gouvernementale
et malheureusement la défaillance de
notre principal partenaire média pro
comme chacun le sait
depuis c'est depuis ce moment on essaie
de trouver des solutions jean marc
miquel air est venu effectivement vous
faire l'état de la situation financière
des du football français schématiquement
au niveau macroéconomique les grandes
masses c'est 1 milliard 800 millions
d'euros de pertes pour les clubs depuis
2019 il ya eu sur la même période
environ 700 millions d'euros de
l'augmentation de capital procéder par
les clubs et environ un demi milliard
d'euros d'apport en fonds courant par
les actionnaires qui jouent leur rôle
mais on voit que le compte n'y est pas
donc parmi les pistes de travail
effectivement sur sur lesquels nous nous
sommes mis
ensemble avec nos équipes il ya ce sujet
de création d'une filiale commerciale
alors c'est pas dans un monde idéal si
tout allait bien on
se serait pas mis dessus mais on doit
vivre avec une réalité la réalité c'est
qu'on est dans un marché global du
football européen avec une concurrence
européenne et déjà on à partir du moment
où nos voisins ont tous regardé cette
hypothèse on pouvait passer à l'économie
nous essayer de la mettre sur la table
on nous l'aurait reproché si on l'avait
pas fait
donc on avance c'est une course
d'obstacles on essaie de faire ça dans
l'ordre en réglant les sujets des uns
après les autres et afin de prendre une
décision prochainement tous ensemble
dans l'intérêt général la volonté
globale est de transformer les
contraintes qui sont les nôtres en
opportunités et de permettre au football
français à travers cette crise majeure
de se renouveler de se réformer de
préparer le le futur dans la meilleure
des meilleures circonstances voilà
comment ce sans plus tarder mais
question et je vais donner la parole à
michel savin qui est donc le rapporteur
de la qpn sur la gaieté notre attise à
sion du sport
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président et le directeur
général de votre présence parmi nous ce
matin
monsieur présidente depuis votre arrivée
à la présidence de la ligue de football
professionnel
d'abord vous avez dû agir agir et ça a
été rappelé par le président des
événements qui auront quand même
bousculé fortement la ligue du football
professionnel français mais dans le même
temps vous avez quand même engagé et il
faut le reconnaître
de nombreux projets de modernisation et
d'évolution pour prendre encore de la
situation de football français
vous avez donc ça a été rappelée été
confrontés les défaillances de mediapro
qui a été un véritable choc bien sûr
pour le football français
mais qui a aussi eu un impact très fort
sur le plan financier
mais aussi au niveau professionnel mais
aussi sur le sport en général avec bien
sûr au travers de la taxe buffet qui a
été impacté par cette défaillance
parce que les budgets au niveau de
l'état étaient calées sur des recettes
qui malheureusement ne sont pas tant pas
été atteint en réaction depuis plusieurs
mois la ligue de football professionnel
travaille sur différentes mesures je
pense que vous allez peut-être nous en
reparler avec eux pour essayer de
répondre aux enjeux économiques
du football français vous préparer des
réformes on a entendu sur la diminution
du nombre de clubs sur le salary cap qui
est un aussi un sujet important et qui
permettra à ces réformes permettront
peut-être aussi d'accompagner
l'évolution du sport professionnel et
notamment du foot en france
mais vous travaillez aussi donc sur le
projet de la mise en place d'une société
commerciale qui visant à commercialiser
donc et droits audiovisuels
alors pour cela le président l'a rappelé
disposition législative doit être adopté
dans le texte de la ppl qui est en
discussion qui met en discussion au
sénat l'article 10 bis à de la
proposition de loi visant à démocratiser
le sport étant donc en émanations
donc si tout se passe bien donc le texte
devrait être définitivement adopté avant
la fin de la session parlementaire fin
février après le passage au sénat au
mois de janvier
ce dispositif a été adopté par un
amendement de séance déposé par un
député
alors nous pouvons déjà regretté qu' à
ce stade aucune étude d'impact n'ait été
réalisé que plusieurs points restent en
suspens donc tu sais les questions du
président que je souhaite aborder les
premières questions concernant cette
société commerciale l'article 10 bis
prévoit dans son alinéa 4 que les
statuts de la société devront définir
les décisions qui nous pourrons être
prise sans l'accord des associés ou
actionnaires minoritaires quelles seront
ses décisions
qu'est ce qui justifie de donner un tel
droit de veto à des actionnaires
minoritaires possédant moins de 20% du
capital
deuxième question la ligue souhaiterait
conserver au moins 80% du capital et des
droits de vote quel sera le profil du ou
des actionnaires que vous souhaitez
pouvoir cueillir qu'elle sera aussi leur
nationalité se prononçant beaucoup que
ya de grandes chances que ce soit des
actionnaires étrangers donc là aussi des
questions à se poser selon la de quelle
de capi peuvent arriver ces fonds
troisième point loups verts du capital à
hauteur de 20% est vraiment nécessaire
alors qu un niveau moins élevé a été
retenu dans d'autres pays comme
l'espagne qui est à 10% que pensez-vous
de retenir un niveau moins élevé autour
de 10% par exemple
quatrième point qu'elles contrôlent la
ligue pourra-t-elle exercée sur le choix
du ou des actionnaires afin de s'assurer
qu'ils ne représenteront aucun risque
pour la discipline l'enjeu étant que les
actionnaires n'est pas de pouvoir de
nuisance ou de deux modifications sur
l'organisation et aux deux du football
professionnel et enfin dernière question
sur ce point là que pensez vous
de renforcer la place de la fédération
française de football notamment sur en
lui donnant un droit de veto temps pour
les statuts de la société que pour le
choix des actionnaires
monsieur ça va je vous remercie se fait
beaucoup beaucoup de questions d'un coup
de bon matin
dans le désordre
renforcer le poids de la fédération dans
notre organisation pour moi ça n'a pas
de sens voilà c'est comme ça ça va être
très clair on est on est dans une
organisation qui est complexe qu'est
lourdes ou l'a dit on en délégation de
service public ministère
fédération ligue le sport professionnel
le football professionnel français est
un sport d'élite on peut pas comparer
une minorité de clubs qui font de
l'entraînement avec le sport à l'école
d'une façon générale on a beaucoup de
contraintes on s'y tient on a beaucoup
de respect pour la fédération on est
ainsi contrôlée je pense que c'est
plutôt de ce qu'il faut faire preuve
d'un peu plus de souplesse que de
renforcer ce contrôle et je dis ça avec
beaucoup d'amitié et de respect pour le
président de la fédération française qui
est quelqu'un que quelqu'un que j'estime
beaucoup ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose sur le processus était
commercial on peut pas le déconnecter
des projets global de réformes qu'on met
en place tout est lié
le monde change la société change le
sport change le football change
et nous on doit le football provincial
changer français et changer radicalement
notre approche si on va être en phase
avec avec la société l'évolution
notamment des droits sportifs donc quand
on décide de réduire le nombre de clubs
déjà c'est pour essayer à terme
d'augmenter nos performances en coupe
d'europe en ayant moins de matches en
semaine de championnat deuxièmement
c'est pour essayer d'avoir plus de
matches premium de concentrer les talons
dans un plus petit nombre d' équipes
puisque le marché audiovisuel est
radicalement changé ces derniers temps
et là où on était en situation de
commercialiser assez facilement la
dizaine de recompter celle de ligue 1
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui il ya en gros deux ou
trois matches qui font l'essentiel de la
valeur et on a des études qui montrent
qu'il ya un ratio de 1 à 30 entre la
valeur d'un match
topten et un match d'un choix 6 à 10
la troisième réforme commande qu'on met
en place également pour changer le notre
modèle c'est la sacralisation de la
formation à la française on a la
meilleure formation mondiale s'est
reconnue et on souhaite passer le
premier contrat professionnel des jeunes
joueurs de 3 à 5 ans ces discussions
qu'on mène maintenant depuis plusieurs
mois avec le syndicat des joueurs qui
évoluent positivement et on veut
bénéficier du talent de cette jeunesse
pour qu'elle reste dans notre
championnat qu'elle grandisse avec nous
qu'elle progresse avec nous plutôt que
de partir dès leur plus jeune âge dans
les pays étrangers
on a également un changement culturel et
qu'on veut mettre en place dans le
football français
c'est une approche beaucoup plus
internationale on a fait l'erreur
collectivement tout ce temps qu'on et
moi le premier en tant qu'administrateur
de la lfp de ce centre est
prioritairement depuis un certain nombre
d'années sur nos revenus domestiques on
a mis derrière et on s'est concentré sur
ses revenus qui était ok augmenté de
façon exponentielle sans se préoccuper
d'aller concacaf télé les recettes
internationales ça nous met un fait
admis un des handicaps fort par rapport
à nos concurrents donc aujourd'hui on
veut on a une vraie volonté de performer
sur la scène européenne
à la fois pour capter les recettes qui
sont versées par l'uefa et qui sont très
importantes mais aussi pour permettre au
football professionnel de clubs français
de permettre à la france de rayonner à
l'international
moi je considère que que le sport en
général et le football en particulier
doit permettre à la france de briller
sur tous les territoires européens on
est fiers quand julian lâché libye
lagnieu le championnat du monde dont le
l'équipe de france de football gagne une
compétition majeure on doit être fier
aussi quand nos clubs performants à
l'international on apporte du baume au
coeur des gens et des bonnes émotions
donc on doit être performant sur la
scène européenne et de cette performance
sur la scène européenne on va gagner en
notoriété à l'international et
mécaniquement on sera en situation de
d'augmenter nos droits internationaux
terrains sur lesquels on a un qu'on a
laissé totalement jachère depuis une
quinzaine d'années est donc ainsi créer
un cercle vertueux qui serait
l'augmentation des recettes sur la scène
européenne des droits internationaux qui
nous permettrait de conserver nos
meilleurs talents d'en recruter d'autres
d'avoir un meilleur spectacle donc
d'avoir le meilleur audience et donc de
relancer
positivement le cycle des droits
pourquoi je vous dis tout ça en
préambule et je réponds sans doute
complètement à côté de vos questions
c'est que on partage 0 malheureusement
on l'a rappelé on a malheureusement à
cause de mediapro une perte de 2 50 % de
mon temps de droits télé de mystique par
rapport à nos principaux voisins qui
sont les concurrents qui sont l'italie
l'allemagne et l'espagne il ya
d'ailleurs aucune raison objective pour
que les droits télé domestique du
championnat français soit 50% inférieurs
à ceux de ses voisins il y en a aucune
on a lyon on a des très grands talents
mondiaux qui jouent en lien on ad le
club qui performent bien cette année en
coupe d'europe donc on voit bien qu
on doit s'accrocher pour trouver une
solution et et le problème qu'on a c'est
qu'on n'a pas de temps on n'a pas de
temps parce que
à très court terme à échéance un an et
demi deux ans on à l'impérieuse
nécessité de recréer une compétition
nationale ultra
performante attrayante spectaculaire
pour maximiser notre prochain appel
d'offres domestique d'une part qui va
arriver très vite en 2023 et on a dans
le même temps
l'impérieuse nécessité également d'être
sûr performant sur la scène européenne
sur la même période à court terme
puisqu'il ya une réforme de l'uefa qui
rentrera qui se mettra en place en 2024
et sans rentrer dans des détails trop
techniques
on est cinquième au classement européen
les cinq premiers au classement européen
pourront avoir quatre places
qualificatives en ligue des champions
qui génère des recettes important pour
les clubs et donc pour le pour la
compétition nationale parle
par conséquence et si on sort de ce
classement je pense que le championnat
de france football professionnel
français mais on sera définitivement en
deuxième division européenne alors je
vais on allait le meilleur football de
sélections nationales je pense que le
promu lot c'est difficile à contester on
a la meilleure formation je vois pas
pourquoi on n'aurait pas l'ambition
d'avoir le meilleur football de clubs et
en tout état de cause si à court terme
on n'est pas capable de rentrer un peu
d'argent frais dans les caisses pong
permettent de nous sauver mais surtout
de rebondir le championnat de france ça
deviendra le championnat de slovénie
avec tout le respect que j'ai pour nous
camara de lui diana elle s'est pas
l'objet de notre mission avec un os donc
donc une fois qu'on a dit ça qu'est ce
qu'on a comme solution
ont cette saison va être sûrs dont les
auditions dncg se termine aujourd'hui
donc on n'a pas les chiffres actualisés
mauvais les communiquera on est sur un
un volant ou encore de 600 et 800
millions de pertes sur le football
français
on va pas les demandes et on va pas
aller demander à l'état s'est laissé
c'est une évidence mais ça va mieux en
le disant
les actionnaires ont déjà fait beaucoup
d'efforts on pense qu'ils sont arrivés à
une certaine limite et est donc
finalement on n'a pas trop tu d'autres
moyens à court terme que de lancer ce
projet de société commerciale mais
encore une fois on va le faire pour des
mauvaises raisons il faut qu'on soit
tous d'accord entre nous c'est ce qu'on
a dit au club il faut que phillies il
faut que tout le monde partage la
philosophie la folie sophie c'est quoi
c'est un vélo et fils et c'est à travers
ce projet avant tout assurer la
pérennité et la compétitivité du
football français sur le moyen et long
terme avant tout et dans un deuxième
temps certes c'est à court terme
permettent de sauver nos clubs de sauver
la filière est de participer à à
relancer également les finances de la
fédération et d'aider le football
amateur si on est d'accord sur cette
philosophie si on est d'accord sur le
projet
ça fait sens de regarder mais ça fait
sens à une condition
c'est sait qu'on a une bonne
valorisation tirons on brade pas nos
actifs clairement donc soit sage oui on
est très très à l'aise sur ce sujet là
on est on a lancé un un process avec eux
un certain nombre de conseils depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois on aura les
premiers indicative la semaine prochaine
mais que les choses soient très claires
si on n'a pas une valorisation qui prend
en compte
notre projet qui ne comprend pas
l'ambition notre projet de long terme et
la place du football français à
l'international dans le fera pas voilà
par contre si on a une valorisation
contre juste qui nous permettra de
sauver notre système de faire bénéficier
de ces fonds est également au monde
amateur
et qui nous permettra donc de repartir
sur des bonnes bases
oui on se posera la question
sérieusement d'avancé alors après le
profil des investisseurs barre
évidemment le premier des investisseurs
et c'est pas un gros mot c'est
majoritairement des sociétés
anglo-saxonnes
on a eu
nos conseils on a eu plus d'une
soixantaine d'appels entrants depuis le
début de l'année deux sociétés
intéressées on en a sélectionné
allez une moitié à peu près celle qui
avait la capacité financière de
participer au projet et
sur la trentaine de sociétés qui sont
candidates aujourd'hui on a 80 % de
sociétés anglo-saxonnes qu'on pignon sur
rue qui font de nombreuses opérations
d'acquisitions en europe occidentale et
en france et on a un process très
sérieux très encadré et et bien
évidemment il n'est pas question de
rééditer les erreurs qui nous est arrivé
de faire notamment dans le choix du du
partenaire audiovisuel que nous avions
fait un brillant en 2018 prix qu'elle
contrôle on a on a tous les contrôles de
tous les contrôles sains reste une
filiale de la lfp
le texte de loi prévoira 1 20% l'idée
c'est absolument pas de céder 20% par
contre on a besoin de dire on s'aide
potentiellement 20% pour maximiser la
valorisation j'insiste si on n'a pas la
relation qu'ont que nous souhaitons
alors on le fera pas donc limiter le
pourcentage disponibles ça n'aurait pas
de sens là aussi
puisque ça tuerait dans l'oeuf toute
ambition de
valorisation importante par contre on
n'a pas la volonté de céder 20% tout de
suite
on est plus sur une dizaine de pourcents
on vend un peu
déjà ça nous permet tester le marché
pour voir quelles valeurs on peut mettre
sur la table auprès de nos clubs après
en terme de contrôle et de gouvernance
on aurait donc au moins 85 ou 90% des
droits
comprendrait bien évidemment compte les
volontés du du partenaire mais
on n'est pas encore entré dans ces
détails là mais quand vous êtes
actionnaire une 10 15% d'une société
c'est pas vous qui qui contrôlait on a
des gens quand même s'ils sont sérieux
et qui sont responsables et l'idée
encore une fois c'est un projet global
c'est un projet commun pour le foot
français mais pour le sport français
dans son ensemble ou on adhère tout ça
la philosophie ont fait où il ya une des
parties prenantes et il s'empara qu on
ne fera pas parce qu'on va passer en
force on pense qu'il faut le faire on
pense que c'est important mais voilà je
sais pas si je vous ai répondu
correctement mais je peux pas trop
entraîné un drone en effet juste pour
forestier de compléter ce qu'a dit
vincent il l'a dit et c'est un point
important qu'on souhaite porter dans un
amendement qu'on vous a déjà communiqué
c'est sur la place de la fédération
aujourd'hui dans le texte tel qu'il a
été adopté par l'assemblée nationale il
n'est pas prévu que la fédération puisse
bénéficier de l'apport que serait
susceptible de faire un investisseur
potentiel donc nous on souhaite et ça
c'est une manière de répondre de façon
détournée à votre question on souhaite
évidemment impliquée la fédération pour
aider la fédération qui rencontrent des
difficultés financières liées aussi à la
crise de mediapro donc ça ça fait partie
de notre de notre volonté d'associer le
mouvement fédéral parce que c'est
évidemment quelque chose qu'on ne peut
pas faire sans l'aval de la fédération
et ça on en est parfaitement conscient
puisque vous l'avez rappelé les statuts
de la filiale commerciale devront être
validée par arrêté ministériel
sur avis de la fédération ce qui veut
dire qu'on peut pas faire complètement
n'importe quoi de même que pour créer
cette filiale il faudra qu'on modifie
les statuts de la ligue pour confier les
missions d'exploitation
commerciale au sein de cette filiale est
donc les modifications statutaires de la
ligue vous le savez sont elles aussi
validé par la fédération puis par le
ministère des sports donc ça fait un
double contrôle finalement on parle d'un
double contrôle par rapport à la
création de cette filiale donc l'idée
selon laquelle la ligue pourrait
agir librement sur ces questions là on
en est on en est assez loin et c'est une
manière de répondre positivement à votre
question le contrôle il existe déjà dans
la modification des statuts de la ligue
et en plus on a souhaité que dans le
texte tel qu'il a été proposé la
fédération est un regard sur les statuts
de la la de la filiale ainsi créé donc
on a des vincent l'a rappelé des
relations extrêmement étroite avec la
fédération française de football et ce
projet elle le suit depuis depuis l'an
depuis l'origine
jean jacques lozach et rapporteur des
crédits budgétaires du sport voyez merci
monsieur président oui je ne reviens pas
sur le sujet de la société commerciale
qui en fait constitue la grande
originalité de la future ppl un
d'ailleurs on voit très bien que c'est
ça qui intéresse la presse et cette
société commerciale concerne
prioritairement le football peut être un
terme indre le rugby mais ça concerne
essentiellement football quant au
passage de trois ans à cinq ans du
premier contrat professionnel
je crois que parce que l'objectif c'est
de garder quand même dans nos clubs
français le plus longtemps possible les
pépites de notes de notre football je
crois que vous nous aurez à vos côtés si
je peux dire bien sûr il s'agit de
mettre en place une possibilité et non
pas une obligation mais maintenant c'est
un sujet qui devenue consensuelle je
dirais dans la famille du football bon
un constat quand même fait que la france
est championne du monde de football
championne du monde des nations mais ça
ne règle pas tous les problèmes et
notamment les problèmes des clubs des
clubs de ligue 1 de ligue 2 en ce qui
concerne en particulier les les réserves
de trésorerie les fonds de roulement
tout à l'heure les chiffres de la dncg
ont été rappelés c'est tout à fait
révélateur d'un système économique qui
paquet pas viable en soi puisque
effectivement par delà la pandémie si on
met de côté la pandémie chaque année à
la fin de la saison le déficit des clubs
ces 500 600 700 millions d'euros ce qui
fait que ensuite les actionnaires
remettent au pot et puis on compte sur
quoi bien sur le marché des joueurs pour
combler les déficits c'est à dire le
trading le transfert alors nous note
notre souhait je dirais c'est d'avoir un
football qui soit le plus durable
possible plus solide plus pérenne
possible et je crois que le législateur
devrait avoir son mot à dire justement
dans le respect des équilibres entre le
foot spectacle foot professionnel le
foot de foot amateur mais on a quand
même le sentiment c'est pas nouveau 1
depuis des années des années
le sentiment que vu de l'extérieur on
assiste quand même une sorte de fuite en
avant ainsi je peux me permettre
l'expression c'est à dire que les les
acteurs du foot agissent comme si on
allait avoir du toujours plus quoi un
toujours plus de matchs toujours plus de
compétition d'ailleurs il ya quelques
années j'avais une seule compétition
européenne pour les clubs maintenant il
y en a trois bons dont toujours plus de
compétition toujours plus de recettes de
de droits télé de marketing de
marchandising et c'est donc on a
l'impression qu'il y à 7 cette fuite en
avant donc la question je dirais très
généraliste que que j'oppose c'est
secouer pas le sentiment qu'il faut
aller quand même vers davantage de
régulation qui davantage de maîtrise
voire davantage de réglementations et et
si oui si oui lesquels bon
deuxièmement je crois qu'on est très
attaché nous ici au club formateur
l'informateur d'aujourd'hui savoir même
si on sait d'ores et déjà que les clubs
formateurs perçoivent une partie des
transferts 1 à terme des joueurs qui ont
été formés justement dans leur centre de
formation ou dans la catégorie jeunes du
club concerné est ce que la ligue il ya
une réflexion qui est lancé pour aider
davantage les clubs les cloches les
clubs formateurs
une troisième question c'est sûr parce
que ça ça fait vraiment partie de vos
prérogatives c'est la répartition des
droits télé est-ce que là aussi vous
réfléchissez un système je dirais un peu
plus solidaire parce que c'est vrai
qu'on prend très souvent comme référence
la ligue anglaise et dans la ligue
anglaise on s'aperçoit que le rapport
entre le plus bénéficiaire est le moins
bénéficiaire est de 1,4 en france il est
de 2,9 donc est-ce que effectivement
on va aller on va s'acheminer vers un
système de répartition qui soit plus
plus égalitaire plus plus solidaire et
puis j'ai envie de dire parce que la
gestion du foot elle est a minima
européenne minimes européenne l'uefa la
fifa et cetera est-ce que vous êtes
prêts en quelque sorte à prendre là la
tête de ce combat pour la limitation du
nombre de contrats professionnels dans
les clubs parce que ça participe à cette
inflation salariale est l'augmentation
des dépenses de fonctionnement on voit
les chiffres un club de ligue 1
aujourd'hui il utilise en moyenne 16
joueurs bon alors pourquoi 25 30 35 40
45 contrat professionnel dans un certain
nombre de clubs surtout qu'au delà du
jeu quoi du 26e joueur il ne joue que
0,1 pour cent du temps de l'ensemble du
championnat donc ça veut dire de très
bons joueurs qui restent sur le banc
pendant tout tout tout la saison et puis
bien sûr
on ne peut pas ne pas évoquer ce qui
marque l'actualité j'arrête c'est la
violence dans les stades parce que là on
est en train de franchir un nouveau
seuil pour la première fois on voit des
spectateurs des santons la pelouse
frappé des joueurs on n'avait jamais vu
ça et je dirais que même les autres
sports ne sont peut-être pas à l'abri de
ce genre de débordement dans le match de
hand ou de voler ou de basket on peut
pourquoi pas assister à ce genre de
débordements donc la question c'est ce
que la boîte à outils juridiques et
suffisante à vos yeux pour lutter contre
la violence dans les stades je sais que
des clubs souhaitent par exemple les
fichier des interdits de stades transmis
par les préfets comporte des
photographies afin de les rendre
exploitables
qu'en pensez vous les clubs soient être
expérimentées voire souhaiterait pouvoir
expérimenter l'utilisation de scanners
corporels à l'entrée des enceintes
sportives etc qu'est ce que vous pensez
de ces mesures alors techniques ou
administratives pour essayer de régler
au plus vite ce fléau merci alors je
vais commencer puis vincent vincent
complétera s'ils savent si sa voix sur
les trois points que vous avez évoquées
pour rebondir sur ce que disait le
sénateur savant on a beaucoup parlé de
mediapro mais on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
de ce qu'on avait fait
avec vincent sur toute cette année en
parallèle de la crise que nous essayons
de gérer dans un certain nombre de
réformes ont été actés ou initiés à la
ligue pour essayer d'aller dans le sens
de la régulation que vous évoquez vous
parliez de calendrier et de charges de
deux matches on a vous l'avez vu réduit
le nombre de clubs en ligue 1 les clubs
ont accepté de mener une réforme pour
passer à 18 clubs en ligue 1 de sorte
que le calendrier soit plus équilibrée
et comment montre l'exemple par rapport
à sa mission et dans le même temps on a
supprimé la coupe de la ligue est donc
serein et totalement en phase nous a
noté m c'est de dire depuis notre
arrivée il ya trop de matches trop de
joueurs trop de clubs par une façon j'ai
trop de compétition voilà donc nous pour
ceux sur ce point précis on réduit
plutôt le nom de compétition et de
rencontres que le club anversois sur la
sur la ligue 2 la ligue 2 a souhaité au
moment où le passage à 18 clubs a été
votée le 3 juin dernier a souhaité se
laisser un peu de temps et demain à
notre assemblée générale la question du
format de la ligue 2 sera également à
l'ordre du jour avec une réflexion qui
est menée au niveau de la fédération
également pour que la pyramide des
compétitions entre la ligue 1 la ligue 2
et national présente un ensemble un peu
plus cohérent qui nous ne le présentait
jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant avec des
critères aussi de régulation sur les
clubs du national donc sur la sur ces
questions de régulation on a aussi lancé
des travaux qui vont aboutir sur la fin
de l'année au delà de du contrat de cinq
ans sur la protection de la formation
avec la limitation des effectifs sans
prendre en compte les joueurs qui
auraient été formés au club pour
supporter la formation comme vous le
comme vous le proposez et puis on
travaille également en lien avec la dncg
sur la mise en place d'un salary cap
donc on est parfaitement conscient du
besoin de régulation que peut avoir
notre activité et parallèlement à son
développement on essaye évidemment de
répondre à cette problématique là
puisqu'en fait concrètement j'ai une
juge les pas j'en ai pas fait état dans
ma première réponse au sénateur ça va
mais en fait tout ce que vous nous dites
on l'a déjà fait donc le contrat de cinq
ans il est pas d il est
directement liée aux os x de limite à la
limitation des effectifs qu'on est en
train de faire valider par les
dirigeants de clubs l'idée ce serait de
plafonner nos effectifs à 24 joueurs
pour éviter effectivement les
aberrations qu'on a pu avoir dans
certains cas vous l'avez on arrivait à
72 contrat professionnel les seules
exceptions qu'on ferait justement à ces
24 joueurs ce serait justement les
jeunes talents qui systématiquement les
jeunes qui auraient signé ce que ce ce
contrat rentrerait plus rapidement dans
les effectifs et sur le terrain donc ça
s'est fait dans le même temps on
travaille avec la dncg et l'uefa sont la
mise en place d'un d'un salary cap qui
prend qui va prendre la forme d'un ratio
maximal de
masse salariale sur le chiffre
d'affaires c'est fait on sait en cours
donc tous ces points de régulation font
partie de notre projet de notre projet
global et des groupes de travail qu'on a
mis en place et qui se réunissent très
régulièrement donc sur ces points je
pense qu'on est totalement totalement
totalement ligne est totalement aligné
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que sur le
contrat de cinq ans
on vous a proposé un amendement pour
porter vous l'avez rappelé la durée à 5
ans sous réserve d'accord collectif et
c'est pour ça que on prépare le travail
avec le n est fait en ce moment pour
voir dans quelles conditions des
contrats de cinq ans pourraient être
proposés à des joueurs qui seraient
vraisemblablement serait pas cinq ans en
une fois mais plutôt trois ans ou plus
des prolongations en fonction de la
participation du joueur à un certain
nombre de matchs sur l'exemple anglais
que vous prenez il est juste papa adapté
du tout à la situation puisque nommé là
je vais répondre est-ce que ça je peux
pas je suis désolé
[Musique]
le coefficient vous mettez en avant de
répartition entre le premier et le
dernier les championnats de la terre
n'est en aucun cas adaptable à la
situation française pour une raison
simple les anglais l'ont mis en place le
jour ils ont eu trois milliards d'euros
de revenus donc moi je ne demande que ça
je vais même aller plus loin c'est le
jour où on a 3 milliards de revenus je
suis tout à fait d'accord pour que tout
le monde ait la même chose
parce que là c'est des bons problèmes à
gérer donc nous on a essayé de le mettre
en place en france et ça nous a on a
scié la branche sur laquelle on est
assis on a une répartition de notre
point de vue qui est très solidaire
depuis une quinzaine d'années beaucoup
plus que vous allez que ce que vous
croyez qu'elle eut pour conséquence de
créer un certain nombre de clubs d'un
bon niveau à niveau correct on va dire
ça mais on avait plus de très bons clubs
donc pour répondre à votre question est
ce qu'on va aller vers une répartition
plus solidaire virgule au moment où on
n'a jamais eu si peu d'argent à la
réponse est non est-ce que autant moi je
suis très favorable aux ruissellements
et à la solidarité dans quand tout va
bien dans le meilleur des mondes et je
suis même jusqu'où je peux aller très
loin sur ces sujets là quand on aura
dressait la barre autant à la verse en
période de crise on n'a qu'une priorité
aujourd'hui c'est de sauver nos
locomotives coûte que coûte son sofa
nollet comme locomotive aujourd'hui on a
plus de championnat si on appris de
championnat on a plus de recettes voilà
donc en fait
la cpo c'est ça la réalité
sur les haies sur les questions de
sécurité pour vous pour pour finir donc
pour finir de répondre peut-être sur les
questions de sécurité
vous l'avez souligné évidemment c'est
quelque chose qui est très important au
niveau de la ligue qu'il a toujours été
puisque les problématiques de sécurité
dans le football c'est quand même un
sujet qui est qui est récurrent avec une
gravité plus ou moins importante c'est
pas la première fois qu'il ya eu des
intrusions sur le sur le terrain ou des
joueurs blessés c'est extrêmement rare
dès qu'on a eu
dès qu'on a vu comment la saison par t
nous avons écrit aux différents
ministères de la justice de l'intérieur
et des sports pour leur signifier qu' on
avait besoin du gouvernement pour
traiter cette question là que la ligue
seul ne peut pas régler le problème de
sécurité dans les stades on a été
entendu puisque d un cycle de réunions a
été initiée et on doit conclure ses
travaux la semaine prochaine le cese par
une réunion avec de nouveau avec gérald
darmanin
roxana maracineanu
eric dupond-moretti
pose mes chers collègues de regrouper
les questions parce que vous êtes
nombreux à vouloir poser des questions
dont va faire par série de quatre en
commençant par jean-raymond gonnet david
assouline michel laugier et jérémy baki
merci président bonjour président
monsieur le directeur bonjour merci pour
ces propos je vais pas dire rassurant
mais en tout cas dans une période où
poulbot français dans une traverse un
moment qui n'est pas simple il est
important d'entendre ce que vous venez
de dire c'est à dire le souci
d'adaptation aux réalités du marché
qu'on ne peut pas nier et le fait qu'il
faille sauver des locomotives sinon on
peut s'occuper d'un championnat mais il
peut sombrer rapidement moi j'ai j'ai
juste quelques questions à votre avis
que faudrait-il modifié dans le
processus d'attribution des droits
audiovisuels pour
garantit enfin pour augmenter les
garanties présentées par les candidats à
éviter la défaillance du type de média
pro la durée des droits est aujourd'hui
de quatre ans et je crois savoir que
vous êtes plutôt favorable à un
allongement de cette durée quels sont
les avantages de l'allongement de cette
durée et quelle est la durée moyenne par
exemple en europe dans les grands
championnats angleterre italie espagne
allemagne
et puis la dernière question
puisque vous vous êtes sensible à
l'adaptation le contrat de cinq ans qui
va on peut comprendre sa logique
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il peut être
assortie au niveau c'est un sujet qu'on
n'a pas abordé encore mais qui est
premier dans le football français on
sait que c'est un boulet que l'on traîne
par rapport aux autres championnats
c'est sur la fiscalité qui s'exerce sur
les joueurs alors c'est un sujet un peu
tabou
mais est-ce que vous pensez que là
dessus il y a au moment justement où on
examine un contrat il est quand même une
contrainte de cinq ans sur une carrière
d'un jeune joueur qui n'est pas
forcément
très longue est ce que vous pensez pas
qu'il peut y avoir un pendant fiscal à
cette réforme
david assouline
bonjour
vous avez faim exposé assez bref et
luminaires et et par les questions voit
progressivement des sujets émerger
je suis frappé que
vos propos ne soient pas surplombé par
des appréciations d'ordre un peu plus
générale qui s'impose à nous nous sommes
des parlementaires sur le sens que l'on
donne aux choses
ça n'a plus de sens que des joueurs
aussi talentueux qu'ils soient puissent
être payés autant puisque vous parlez
d'argent essentiellement
ça détruit tous les repères que nous
essayons de construire dans la société
pour les jeunes
premièrement deuxièmement
la violence qui a dans les stades
est aussi liée à ce cette perte de sens
puisque on a voulu dire avec le sport
avec cette communion avec avec tout tout
ce que signifie le sport
dans l'éducation de nos enfants
et vous
toute la bonne volonté vous avez pas ce
que vous aimez le foot et je peux vous
dire que je suis un passionné de foot
vous en arrivez à avoir cette stratégie
que vous résumer par une phrase il faut
sauver nos locomotives on verra après
pour le reste si on laisse aux veaux il
y aura un entraînement ça me fait penser
au ruissellement de du président de la
république mais je
je je vous dis et je vous pose la
question
y compris du point de vue de ceux qui
qui regardent le foot et qu'il aime
la valeur du championnat français
par rapport à la valeur du championnat
britannique
sait que vous regardez n'importe quel
mac du championnat britannique vous
voyez du grand spectacle
quelque chose tout à fait étonnant or
comme vous dites dans le championnat
français quand ce ne sont pas les
locomotives qui joue ça devient moyen
voire médiocre
donc le problème du rehaussement de la
valeur même du spectacle du championnat
français c'est de faire que l'ensemble
des clubs qui sont déjà une élite parce
que tout le football amateur derrière
puisse être emmenés vers le haut
pour le bien même des locomotives parce
que vous voyez bien aussi dans les
résultats que quand le psg joue toute
l'année avec des équipes d'un certain
niveau les joueurs sont plus ou moins
des motivés quand ils arrivent en ligue
des champions on peut pas dire qu'ils
ont été préparés au match de très très
haut niveau donc je
remets en cause le fait même que pour la
qualité et la valeur on puisse se baser
sur le fait que la stratégie c'est les
locomotives
laisser dire ça
vous allez
signer avec si vous pouvez
rapidement parce qu'il ya pas mal de
bien sûr bien sûr mais donc c'est une
question est un désaccord et les
échanges peuvent avoir lieu
sur la valeur des droits et sur les
droits j'ai commis un rapport sur le
sport elle est en général à la
télévision vous voyez bien que la
catastrophe médias trop pouvait se
prévoir on a eu des fuites en avant il
ya eu lieu le déjà avec orange qui avait
complètement avec des droits bon voilà
ce que ça a donné mediapro et quand la
boussole est au plus offrant aux plus
merveilleux et qu'on ne voit pas ce qui
peut
consolider et faire en sorte qu'ils
viennent pérennité et un sens aux choses
on aboutit à ce type de catastrophe il
peut y en avoir d'autres demain donc la
société commerciale pourquoi pas mais
réfléchir au fait que de toute façon il
y aura un problème demain par rapport à
la culture football qui est très
populaire que ce sport est maintenant
payant pour ceux qui veulent le voir
et que on paye des joueurs des sommes
gigantesques et ce à un moment donné ça
ne peut plus durer y compris dans
beaucoup de pays qui nous entourent en
espagne etc il commence à parler du
salaire des joueurs et c'est peut-être
pour ça que certains viennent au front
dans l'élite il ya le psg qui a de
l'argent quand même donc voyons comment
on fait que tous les autres en est aussi
michel j
merci monsieur le président en poste
dans les rues n'y a pas que des biens
soulignent qu'ils aiment le football
d'autres aussi et lui passionné de paris
saint germain boissy plutôt l'olympique
de marseille mais bon comme ça ça
précise les choses brabant à la crise
sanitaires à venir lorsqu'on a déjà vécu
quelques crises la série qui va arriver
est ce qu'aujourd'hui les clubs de son
prêt matériellement et surtout est-ce
qu'ils sont prêts elle nous nouvelles
diminutions de recettes dans leur
équilibre financier
deuxièmement on voit dans les grands
clubs étrangers le bayern de munich par
exemple où le barça énormément deux
anciens joueurs font partie des équipes
dirigeantes et c'est moins le cas en
france comment vous l'expliquez
et dans cette commission nous avons
débattu longuement avec des propos
vraiment de très haute qualité sur la
loi sur le gel des mages du 5 mai
devant voter mais nous avons regretté
qu'à même que depuis le 5 mai 1992 les
instances du football n'ait pas pris
leurs responsabilités
nous avons pris les nôtres alors
j'aimerais un petit peu quand
j'expliquais même si vous êtes à la tête
de la ligue depuis peu comment vous
expliquer ce silence et cette énergie
merci beaucoup et on reste sur marseille
le sénateur
merci monsieur le président président
labrune je reviendrai pas sur tous les
enjeux
sur la future société commerciale ça a
été très bien dit mes collègues
notamment michels avait imposé les
questions très bien je reviendrai pas
non plus sur les enjeux économiques
beaucoup de questions ont été posées
celle avantage de passer en dernier dans
le tour de parole mais je me
concentrerai plutôt sur
la violence que nous avons dans les
stades depuis le début de la saison le
disiez tout à l'heure c'est pas à des
faits nouveaux en revanche j'ai pas
souvenir en tout cas au cours des 20
dernières années que nous ayons eu comme
ça et une multiplication de faits plutôt
grave depuis le début de la saison sur
un exercice ou même pas sur un exercice
en réalité sur trois quatre mois de
compétition très rapidement sur le sujet
et suite à la reprise notamment dans la
presse du rapport de ruddy buquet
l'arbitré qui a officié lors du match
olympique lyonnais et de marseille du
préfet de la direction département de la
sécurité de nouvelles questions se
posent et notamment vis-à-vis de la
ligue est il vrai que la lide
privilégier une reprise j'ai vu les
déclarations y compris monsieur labrune
dans la presse et aux déclarations là
dessus alors même que d'une part à
l'arbitré était très hésitant
visiblement c'est dire qu'avant même le
jet de bouteille à la 4e minute ruddy
buquet avait déjà dû faire une annonce
dès la 2e minute pour les jets de
briques et et de bouteilles déjà ce qui
permettait mois tort un peu le coup de
la thèse de l'acte isolé en fait je
revienne pas sur le détail il déroulé du
calendrier de cette soirée là mais les
propos qui ont fait suite et ces
derniers jours notamment du président
aulas je les cite ce que je les ai pas
de mémoire
toujours dans le rapport buquet la
compétition dépend de la lfp s'adressant
à ruddy buquet vous de la fff je fait
malheureusement partie du comité
exécutif de la fédération et ça ne va
pas en rester là
jean michel aulas toujours sur twitter
hier en tout cas indiqué
qu'il cherchait à trouver une solution
et donc pourquoi pas passer à 6
remplaçants dans un match comme ça ça
inciterait le joueur blessé à reprendre
plus rapidement il nous appartient pas
de commenter ces propos ceci étant dit
ces propos là sont nature à hystériser
encore plus le débat de mon point de vue
et créer les conditions que nous soyons
dans les semaines et les mois à venir à
nouveau confronté à de pareils
débordements ne pensez-vous pas non plus
que la décision de la commission de
discipline de la lfp suite aux incidents
entre le match ogc nice l'olympique de
marseille n'a pas créé une sorte de
jurisprudence
dangereuse pour la suite je dis ça parce
que nous avions à ce moment là une
consensus assez générale à la fois de la
classe politique du monde sportif des
journalistes enfin de tout le monde pour
dire de tels incidents doivent créer une
jurisprudence de dire match perdu pour
l'ensemble des clubs fauteurs de
troubles voilà c'est une interrogation g
il faut que l'on regarde ça de manière
plus précise et je dis pas ça parce que
cet après midi à la commission de
discipline qui se réunit sur les
incidents du match ol om enfin dernière
question j'ai vu en début d'année qui
avait à titre expérimental
qu'il était envisagé je crois que c'est
à toulouse si je me trompe pas le retour
des fumigènes dans les stades pour
regarder si on ne pouvait pas imaginer
de généraliser cela je voulais savoir un
peu si vous aviez déjà et j'allais dire
à mi-chemin une première analyse de ça
parce que on voit bien en réalité qu il
ya de plus en plus de tribunes qui ferme
qui ont des sursis pour utilisation de
fumigènes ça participe de mon point de
vue y compris aux sports populaires que
que nous voulons sans forcément qu'il y
ait eu de débordement avec ces fumigènes
là et c'est regrettable de jouer dans
des tribunes dans des stades vides ou
dans des tribunes vides alors que pour
le coup nous pourrions être à la fois
très dur s'il y avait des débordements
liés aux fumigènes et à la fois leur
permettre le retour dans les stades
parce que c'est aussi ce qui
permet l'attractivité de notre
championnat de nos stades mais aussi ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure par
rapport aux recettes éventuellement
futur à récupérer donc je m'arrête là
monsieur le président merci qui
c'est le président monsieur rouge et si
vous voulez répondre à ces questions
merci sur la question de la violence
pour rappel il ya une quinzaine d'années
il ya eu des morts autour des stades
quand vous dites que vous n'avez pas le
souvenir d'avoir vu des événements aussi
grave aussi avec des événements but mais
bien plus grave
bien plus loin bien plus loin après je
vais vous dire ce que j'en pense je les
dis mais je vais vous le redire
le stade de football c'est le reflet de
l'état de la société
ni plus ni moins et la société française
post crise sanitaire ou en pleine crise
sanitaire elle est malade elle est
inquiète elle en bois
csss divise et elle est un peu folle et
donc le football français est pas
responsable de la folie des gens alors
est ce qu'on te prendre des mesures plus
adaptées plus forte là je vous entends
est ce que la commission discipline a
pris sur le match nice l'olympique de
marseille une décision
de référence j'en sais rien je pas le
plus beau je suis pas le mieux placé
pour en parler paradoxalement parce
qu'on a un arsenal de sanctions qui est
très limité mais en tout cas on agit en
effet de laisser enchaîner on agit mais
il faut pas se tromper
on a un arsenal de sanctions qui n'est
que sportif alors qu'on a des problèmes
de violence d'indy individuel donc on
peut pas la commission discipline ne
peut pas régler elle tout seul loin de
là les problèmes de sécurité dans les
stades voilà donc cesser le sens et vos
questions sont nombreux sur ces
questions là sur ces problématiques de
sécurité c'est le sens des travaux que
l'on mène depuis de nombreuses années
puisqu'on l'a dit les problèmes de
sécurité sont à nouveau ils ont été à un
niveau très très élevé en 2010 ce qui a
été
le un point de départ d'un certain
nombre de mesures législatives prises en
matière d'interdiction de stades
notamment de création de la dlna enfin
les relations entre la libye et le
ministère de l'intérieur ont été très
étroite à ce moment là et ces
problématiques sont prises en compte de
façon très sérieuse au niveau de la
ligue et comme le disait vincent l'ailé
le pouvoir de la nique se limite à un
pouvoir disciplinaire vis-à-vis de ses
membres et donc vis-à-vis des clubs et
des seuls clubs donc on ne peut pas nous
aller au delà de ces sanctions et on
peut commenter les décisions de la
commission de discipline à dessin on
peut trouver qu'elles sont trop faire ne
trop laxiste nous vous comprenez bien
que que nous devons nous avons un devoir
de réserve absolu par rapport aux
décisions de la commission de discipline
est encore plus absolu quand ce soir
elle doit se réunir pour traiter
justement de la question de du match
olympique de lyon olympique lyonnais
olympique de marseille donc du coup ça
nous ça nous oblige à ne pas pouvoir
répondre par rapport aux questions que
vous posez sur ce match précisément je
vous renvoie au communiqué qu on a fait
le soir même sur les conditions d'arrêt
de la rencontre tout à l'heure je
j'évoquais les travaux que nous
conduisons avec les trois ministères
justice intérieur et sport et qui
doivent conduire à une clarification
très précise des conditions dans
lesquelles la cellule de crise se
réunira et prendra ses décisions pour
qu'il n'y ait plus de décisions
l'ong comme ça a été le cas et dans un
dans une confusion qui laisse à penser
que
les uns et les autres n'ont pas pris
leurs responsabilités
il nous appartient pas ici de commenter
les propos du préfet du rhône ni de jean
michel aulas ni de l'olympique de
marseille donc on se rend tiendra là en
revanche et vous avez raison de le citer
ces incidents ont
masqué un travail de longue haleine qui
est menée depuis la crise à la création
de l'instance nationale du supportérisme
auxquelles on participe activement pour
mener un certain nombre
d'expérimentations sur des sujets qui
sont on va dire normalement
politiquement incorrect on pense aux
tribunes debout sécurié qui ont été
remises en place de façon expérimentale
dans un certain nombre de clubs pour
répondre à une problématique de des
supporters et puis des tests de craquage
de fumigènes encadrés comme vous faites
référence c'est ces expérimentations
sont menées de façon
extrêmement précise
sur la base d'un cahier des charges qui
a été établie au sein de business et
auquel les clubs doivent répondre quand
ils veulent mener ses opérations là avec
leurs supporters il y en a une à
toulouse
qu'en début de saison pardon et le
week-end dernier à clermont qui s'est
très bien passée où effectivement ça
permet d'avoir une utilisation en avant
match au moment de l'entrée des joueurs
de fumigènes de façon encadrée et de
répondre ainsi à une problématique
souhaité parler par les supporters donc
oui on est
favorable à ce que vous évoquez et oui
on travaille activement à ces questions
et enfin au delà des sanctions
disciplinaires que l'on que l'on peut
prononcer via la commission discipline
on est évidemment au soutien de tout ce
qui peut se passer
en matière de sanctions individuelles
puisque dès lors que les individus sont
identifiés comme le l'auteur du jet de
bouteille où l'auteur du salut nazi sur
nice marseille nous nous constituons
parties civiles systématiquement pour
que des poursuites individuelles soit
soit effectuée à ce sujet effectivement
la ppl peut être l'occasion de porter si
vous le souhaitez un certain nombre de
propositions la question de
l'allongement des interdictions
judiciaires de stade peut se poser même
si aujourd'hui on peut regretter et ça
fait partie des discussions qu'on a avec
le ministère de la justice donc il n'est
pas question ici de critiquer quiconque
mais les les laissant force est de
constater que les la durée maximale de 5
ans et déjà rarement atteinte on en a
beaucoup parlé sur l'auteur du jet de
bouteille sur lyon mais c'est un fait
rarissime et il est plus fréquent que
des incidents de cette nature soit
sanctionné d'un simple rappel à la loi
ou de ce qu'on regrette
évidemment pour essayer de répondre
rapidement aux autres questions vincent
complète sur la situation sanitaire on
n'a pas beaucoup parlé c'est quelque
chose sur lequel on est très discret
mais sachez que le travail des clubs est
exemplaire depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire de tous les clubs
professionnels pas que pas que dans le
le football mais aussi dans toutes les
disciplines sportives professionnelles
qui sont organisées un peu tout de la
même manière avec des commissions
médicales composées d'experts
infectiologues qui ont permis de suivre
au plus près l'évolution de la pandémie
on s'est adapté
systématiquement aux recommandations
gouvernementales pas plus tard que
vendredi dernier quand le port du masque
a été rendue obligatoire dans les rp
l'information a été communiquée
immédiatement
auprès des clubs les clubs sont
parfaitement organisés à la fois d'un
point de vue opérationnel pour
l'organisation des matches et d'un point
de vue médical sur le suivi de leurs de
leur effectif on a reçu avec vincent la
semaine dernière l'ensemble des médecins
qui ont contribué à ces travaux là et
qu'on doit ici remerciés par rapport à
tout le travail qui a été fait sur sur
ces questions là donc géré par rapport à
la question qui était posée oui on est
prêt d'un point de vue opérationnel nom
n'est pas près d'un point de vue
économique évidemment si les jours je
venais à être limité ça serait un
désastre par rapport à une situation
économique est déjà
qui est déjà extrêmement tendu on vous
l'a rappelé donc faut bien dissocier la
question opérationnel le sport
professionnel vous le savez est un un
milieu où le suivi médical est
extrêmement important donc les clubs
sont parfaitement staff et pour tester
les joueurs dont je le rappelle
l'effectif est à 95% vacciner
aujourd'hui les staffs professionnels
sont
totalement vacciner
il me reste la question du contrat de
cinq ans dans les discussions qui sont
menées puisque ce que ce qui est ce que
vous avez ce que le sénateur savard
appelé c'est c'est la question de ça ça
doit être pris par accord collectif il
ya deux éléments le fait qu' il y aura
sans doute une limite au nombre de
contrat par clubs tout ça reste à
définir et puis bien évidemment la
question de la fiscalité
sur les salaires des joueurs est un
élément important
[Musique]